DICE the aubergine and fry in hot olive  oil until colors on all sides then add a  finely sliced onion and chopped garlic  cook until tender add cooked butter  beans and pomegranate molasses which is  a sweet thick and glossy tankey  reduction of pomegranate juice season  next add a can of chopped tomatoes bring  to a simmer and cook until the aubergine  has a gloriously soft and silky texture  stir through chopped mint pile onto  toasted bread and finally for a lovely  salty tang crumble over some creamy feta  cheese minimum preparation for slow cook  for maximum flavor over jeans like  you've never tasted before next add a  bay leaf and some fresh thyme sprigs  then the sausages go back in well  beautiful all that was reduced down to  it's amazing nice tomato sauce